I've seen a lot of youtubers make these
introspective visual poetry pieces and I
wanted to make one of my own hotel rooms
are such interesting places everything
that's in it is supposed to make you
comfortable for living and everything
that's in it has been lived in by so
many unknown faces there was an
overwhelming sense of coziness and
loneliness
at the same time it makes you wonder has
anyone ever proposed in here has anyone
ever died in here has anyone had the
best or the worst day of their life in
here the anonymity of a hotel room can
sometimes lead you to start taking your
own liberties what if I order too much
room service what if I wear the robe
that they gave me what if I pee with the
door open what if while peeing with the
door open a hotel robber runs through
the hallway yielding a knife and a
housekeeping lady in an attempt to save
her own life seek solace in my room
barges through my door only to find a
grown woman pants down seep up pissing
with the door open and in my shock and
embarrassment I yell something at her
completely incoherent like greed or stop
it Satan and we linger in three seconds
of the longest silence either one of us
has ever experienced finally she
silently and slowly shuts the door
because we both knew I couldn't reach it
on my own without lifting my bare butt
ass off of the toilet I pretend to wash
my hands for far too long as I hear her
foots about pretending to forget what
she had seen until the coast is
announced clear and I hear her leave
I spend paranoid hours in my hotel room
knowing that there's a housekeeping lady
that has seen me in my most vulnerable
state and wondering if she noticed that
I had been eating hummus out of the
carton with a spoon what is she telling
the other housekeepers she didn't die
today but
part of me died today that lady almost
stole my cooter and I'll never really
know her because I don't know her name
and I can't look her up online and see
her Instagram see if she's joining
Facebook groups they're like I've seen
20% of grace helbig's machine we're
liking Tumblr posts that are like Grace
has changed and she comments that you
know what else has changed about grace
her idea of ever taking a risk in her
life ever again hotel rooms are an
interesting place I don't know